Trascrizione: Patrizia C Romeo Tomasini
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
DM: Ciao.
Le presentazioni:
Questo ragazzo è Tito
e io sono il papà di Tito.
12 anni fa, quando lui è nato,
anch'io avevo un nome.
Ormai l'ho perso.
Sono diventato, a tutti gli effetti,
solo il papà di Tito
e in certi ambienti,
soprattutto calcistici,
anche il papà di Nico,
ecco, sono l'Innominato manzoniano.
Tito ha una paralisi cerebrale
dalla nascita
che rende difficoltosi i suoi movimenti.
Per camminare lui usa un deambulatore,
che è quello lì,
e quando non ha il deambulatore vicino
usa me come stampella.
Io sono sempre pronto,
al servizio di mio figlio, come stampella.
Però anch'io lo uso come stampella,
infatti mi aggrappo a lui.
Lui si aggrappa a me per camminare
e io mi aggrappo a Tito per parlare,
per pensare,
soprattutto,
da quando è nato lui,
anche per sentire.
Sono stato un paralizzato emotivo
per tutta la vita,
diciamo che lui è una stampella
molto efficace.
Il TED dà un premio
di un milione di dollari
a tutti quelli che sono in grado
di cambiare il mondo.
Io dovrei dare un milione
di dollari a Tito
perché lui il mondo non l'ha cambiato
e non lo cambierà mai,
però ha cambiato il mio mondo,
il mio piccolissimo, minuscolo,
meschino mondo.
L'ha stravolto, l'ha ribaltato,
sempre in meglio, curiosamente.
È diventato proprio...
Sei la mia energia pulita,
sei tutto,
sei la mia pace universale, Tito.
Dovrei dare un milione di dollari
anche a mia moglie
perché lei ha avuto l'unica idea
buona della nostra esistenza,
che è riprodotta in questo video.
Tito in quarta elementare ha cominciato
ad andare a scuola da solo
usando le rampe
della Maratona di Venezia,
due rampe, in questo caso,
della Maratona di Venezia.
Anna, mia moglie, ha avuto
la buonissima idea
di far riprendere Tito - da me purtroppo,
vedete che non sono un bravo cameraman -
ma di riprendere Tito mentre faceva
il suo percorso fino alla scuola
e dopo l'ha inviato all'Ufficio
Eliminazione Barriere Architettoniche
del Comune di Venezia e, contrariamente
a tutto quello che ci si aspetta
dall'Amministrazione Pubblica,
si sono dati da fare in modo veloce,
efficiente, senza burocrazia,
e hanno tenuto le rampe fino alla fine
dell'anno scolastico, quell'anno lì.
Adesso la cosa è molto cresciuta
perché abbiamo coinvolto il Guggenheim,
che è un museo tutto accessibile
internamente,
ma a cui non si arrivava.
Sono anche questi
i problemi delle città.
Le leggi costringono il Guggenheim
ad avere tutti ascensori, eccetera,
però non ci arrivi.
Adesso sì. Grazie a Tito...
Tito: Anche a Pinot.
DM: Anche a Pinot, scusami,
anche la Fondazione Pinot, bravo,
è coinvolta in questo progetto.
(Applausi)
La mia stampella serve anche
alle mancanze di memoria.
Allora un milione di dollari
anche a mia moglie
perché è molto oneroso
essere il TED di se stessi
se non hai buone idee tu stesso,
devi cominciare a distribuire in giro.
Poi, l'unica cosa che posso dire
della nostra esperienza,
che mi ha toccato personalmente,
ho scritto sull'argomento,
e che ho vissuto in maniera più profonda,
è il contrario di quel video meraviglioso
che abbiamo visto,
di quella ragazza inglese
che va sott'acqua.
Lei ha superato i limiti.
Questa è una storia di superamento.
Lei ha oltrepassato le barriere.
Noi, invece, no.
Noi abbiamo superato
la necessità di superare.
Noi siamo oltre il superamento
perché viviamo bene con i nostri limiti
con i nostri ostacoli, me, lui,
sua mamma, suo fratello.
Noi viviamo bene
nel nostro mondo limitato,
pieno di barriere.
Le uniche barriere che siamo riusciti
a superare
sono stati due benedetti ponti
che lo portano a scuola.
L'episodio, l'aneddoto chiave
che ci ha fatto veramente capire
come si faceva a superare
la necessità di andare oltre,
di superare i limiti,
di abbattere le barriere,
è successo quando Tito aveva 7 mesi.
Avevamo appena saputo che lui
a causa di un errore
dell'ospedale di Venezia...
ho elogiato l'Amministrazione Pubblica,
ma qua tolgo tutti gli elogi
perché lui è frutto di un errore medico
flagrante dell'ospedale...
Comunque, a 7 mesi,
appena avuta la notizia,
io leggevo il giornale sul divano,
lui era qua, sulle mie ginocchia,
sua mamma stava facendo da mangiare,
ed è inciampata sul tappeto
e... bumba! È caduta per terra.
Improvvisamente Tito ha cominciato
a scoccorarsi dal ridere, e rideva...
ma una risata proprio che veniva da....
perché lui, ecco, lui è uno che ride
in tutte queste circostanze.
E lì noi abbiamo capito
l'essenziale della nostra vita,
cioè lui cade, ma lei cade,
io cado, il fratello cade.
Siamo una famiglia di cadenti e di caduti.
Grazie.
(Applausi)